what was it right before cover you guys
were going to tour Russia and Ukraine
yeah and that um of course can't happen
now isn't that crazy I mean the [ __ ] is
we got to meet with President zielinski
just a couple weeks ago on Zoom which
was oh no kidding yeah imagine dragons
met with President zielinski yeah I'm on
Zoom how does that happen the band is
really big in Ukraine it's like one of
our biggest territories it's like Harry
Potter and Imagine Dragons are like very
cultural like big in in uh Ukraine so
yeah I think we just spoke up about how
we felt about the war and they reached
out and asked if we want to meet Zoom
with zelinski we said well we absolutely
want to be presents let's count I met
with him and uh what do you talk do you
get nervous for something because he
could probably say to yourself well I
mean who am I to be meeting with
President zielinski who's in the middle
of war with Russian but I understand why
he's meeting with you you guys have a
lot of clout with people I guess his
goal
is to ask you to either visit the
country or to talk about the country and
keep it on people's minds so they don't
forget what's going on that's the main
thing he asked is he said when you're on
stage tell the people of America to not
forget about us and I thought that
wasn't it was important also because I
feel we're in this day and age where
people are like words mean nothing right
because we're so inundated with it it's
like yeah yeah words whatever but he was
like no words not like enough people
talk about on Twitter then it's trending
and then it gets in a headline and then
politicians feel more pressure he's like
please just like tell people when you're
going on tour don't forget about us you
know war is Raging on here that that
helps yeah you know since you're so
popular there it must be a special
heartache for you guys to see
what's going on there I mean these
people had a nice life that I mean for
what what is this guy invading their
country for for to what end what more
power more I mean it is just sickening
it must have been unbelievable to talk
to zielinski and sit there it's really
one of the most inspiring people even
though you know it was just you know
over through a screen it was still just
being in his digital presence had like
this this air of seriousness to it and
it really uh you know you you got a
sense of the way people are suffering
and the way he has this willingness and
this strength and resolve to fight back
in this determination he's not laying
down and you know he he's he's in it
till the end